bienvenue à tous sur public sénat à
montjaux perrine bienvenue pour ses
duels des sénatoriales premier en avant
les élections sénatoriales de septembre
prochain nous allons donner quatre duels
quatre duels avec les grandes voix du
sénat que je vous présente aujourd'hui
jean pierre raffarin bonjour bonjour
sénateur ump de la vienne vice-président
du sénat et face à vous didier guillaume
président du groupe ps ici au sénat
sénateur de la drôme alors nous allons
revenir ensemble sur la réforme
territoriale qui vient d'être examinée
en première lecture par le sénat l'image
du sauna sortait affaibli de cette
discussion puisque aucune carte des
régions des sorties du sénat affaibli
c'est vous qui le dit didier guillaume
on va en débattre plus généralement quel
est le rôle quelle est la place pour le
sénat en 2014 en vue bien sûr des
élections sénatoriales du 28 septembre
prochain alors première question pour
vous jean pierre raffin ça aurait dû
être le texte phare du sénat pendant
cette session le redécoupage territorial
cette nouvelle carte des régions est ce
que vous avez manqué une occasion de
peser sur ce futur axe de
décentralisation d'abord je voudrais
vous dire que le mot de l ne t'avais un
peu brutal donc nous avons des
discussions démocratiques et
respectueuses et donc je suspends en
duel et je n'ai pas de volonté agressé
d'autant plus que sur ce sujet le sénat
avait décidé une mission une mission qui
a conduit un rapport de monsieur crac
âgée qui a été votée à la quasi
unanimité et qui au fond donné
il ya quelques semaines donc il y n'est
possible et le sénat a une pensée sur
ces sujets il se trouve que le
gouvernement a bousculé un peu son
calendrier qu'une carte a été quelque
peu improvisée et que l'on nous a
annoncé une seconde lecture est ce que
nous avons souhaité c'est qu'il y ait un
débat y compris à l'assemblée nationale
mais surtout dans les territoires pour
éviter une carte d'en haut une carte
raisonnable a joué un peu la montre que
non et c'est une erreur c'est une erreur
ça ce serait probablement malveillants
c'est simplement que moi je ne me sens
pas capable de faire la somme de
l'alsace et de la lorraine simplement en
un après-midi savez les gens se
connaissaient alors vous connaissez leur
histoire voulait rapprocher comme ça
toutes les deux sans discuter avec le
délégué ou non mais je ne parle je pense
pas du tout cela fait 30 ans et
d'improvisation l'apparenté
précipitations des trente ans qu'on
parle de ça monsieur balladur a fait une
première carte avec une dizaine de
régions il ya plus de dix ans il eu des
rapports qui ont été faits dans le
rapport à farenc attinger ya aucune
improvisation aucune précipitation et
qu'aurions nous disent il préside la
république n'avait pas fait une carte
qui est ce qu'elle est mais aujourd'hui
force est de constater qu'on interroge
chaque sénateur et chaque sénateur a sa
propre idée non moi je ne pense pas
qu'ils aient de l'improvisation jeudi
c'est tout simplement la situation est
simple soit on fait comme on l'a
toujours fait sur les collectivités
territoriales
c'est à dire on ne bouge pas soit on
avance et pour avancer il ya deux choses
à mon avis très simple la première c'est
de réduire le nombre de régions et la
deuxième c'est de clarifier les
compétences sur le fond
dans un rayon plus d'avoir à 16h dit
qu'il était avec la bretagne à 18h qu'il
est avec poitou charentes et au total à
20 heures on apprend comme ça que
poitou-charentes parce qu'elle
négociations l'elysée entre 3 4
personnes qu'aux points touchant sera
avec le centre il s'agit ajoute entité
culturelle il s'agit de langues il
s'agit de culture il s'agit de flux
économie ça demande quand même de la
pondération autant on peut être capables
chacun dans notre région de dire quoi ça
veut dire qu'il fallait plus de temps
parce qu'il fallait plutôt essuie tout
mais très peu de temps mais suffisamment
par exemple pour que chaque région
puisse s'exprimer que les territoires
sexuels que les grands journaux un
domaine que l'événement serait grand
joueur je le pense mais je ne veux pas
faire un procès je suis d'accord il faut
une réforme je suis d'accord il faut des
grandes régions je suis d'accord il faut
garder de la proximité donc il ya celui
lee a dévoilé à permettre je promets
lyon c'est pour ça qu'on a de lecture
vous c'est pour ça que je te les légers
une occasion ratée c'est une occasion
ratée à ce que c'est pas un drame mais
c'est une occasion ratée parce qu'en
fait honnêtement jean pierre raffarin
est lui aussi un peu pas forcément de
vous mais un positionnement liées aux
élections sénatoriales
mais ça bouge on n'est pas que ça bouge
maintenant peut-être s'est pas imposé
d'intention c'est possible qu'il y ait
eu ça honnêtement une maladresse mais
seulement de m on aurait peut-être pu le
faire dit
je vais vous dire moi j'étais très déçu
quand en alsace le référendum a été
négatif moi je pensais que ça aurait été
formidable ça allait changer totalement
le visage de la france si le bas rhin le
haut rhin et la région alsace faisait à
une seule et même entité et ça aurait
été exceptionnel qu'est ce qui s'est
passé on a mis tellement de contraintes
à la pour avoir interrogé on a interrogé
le débat a duré des semaines et des
semaines on en a même fait un référendum
articipation oui et on a même fait un
référendum qui fait qu'une fine et ça ne
s'est pas fait je crois sur ces sujets
bien sûr il faut interroger questionner
etc mais le parlement doit prendre ses
responsabilités parlement et le sénat
mais le pas le scénario s'annonce
république parce que l'image du sénat
est en vie aujourd'hui vous le voyez
mais vous savez le le sénat doit pas
travailler dans la précipitation
moi je suis heureux de savoir maintenant
que dans ma propre région mon grand
quotidien régional a fait un sondage
maintenant dont je connais l'opinion de
la majorité de la population de poitou
charentes j'ai vu que des universitaires
s'étaient exprimés j'ai vu que le débat
et c'est plus facile d'arbitrer contre
les uns et les autres se sont exprimés
mais je crois pas que ce soit un débat
essentiel puisque là il s'agit de
quelques semaines de quelques quelques
mois peut-être donc
l'essentiel c'est de faire une réforme
les vrais sujets de désert si on veut
des élections le vrai sujet décembre
2015 je pense que cette affaire était
fait de manière maladroite
il ya une volonté de changer les règles
électorales et je trouve que là ce n'est
pas ça c'est pas changer les règles
hexagonal c'est de se dire avançant le
rapport que vous avez commis avec jean
avec krattinger c'était en 2009 on peut
pas dire c'est dans la précipitation
nous sommes en 2014 ça fait six ans cinq
ans maintenant il faut bouger on sait
très bien où on pourrait aller qu'est ce
qui se passe c'est que ce qu'on appelle
c'était malheureusement être apte à
jouer les balles et baron de cause les
barons locaux qui les barons locaux de
droite comme de gauche voient la réforme
territoriale à l'aune de leur propre
territoire et c'est pour ça que me
semble-t-il plus que des sondages locaux
on peut tout renferme en fassions de
l'issue des sondages on n'aurait pas
aboli la peine de mort et on n'aurait
pas fait lives et j'ai donc il faut que
le parlement prenne ses décisions ses
décisions elles sont un pur combat s'est
passé pas l'essentiel chapitre mais on
peut estimer à priori pour la seconde
lecture à l'automne prochain un
consensus devrait être trouvée ici moi
je sais que le sénat est tout à fait
capable de faire une carte est de
proposer une carte nous l'avons dit en
séance au ministre nous avons tendu la
main ce que nous demandons c'est qu'il y
ait le temps de la discussion parce que
autant chacun peut dire sa vérité en
fonction de son territoire autant il est
difficile de voir les conséquences sur
les autres et ça avait un côté un peu
désagréable dans certaines réunions de
vivre les régions allant quant à moi je
veux pas du centre à moi je voudrais la
lorraine à moi je voudrais champagne
ardenne c'est la france et la france on
a manipule pas comme ça c'est pour city
ne crois pas d'une annonce assis je peux
promettre que je n'y crois pas du tout
je ne me sens pas du tout je vous dis
que en novembre en octobre je vous fiche
mon billet que quand cette loi reviendra
au sénat il ne sortira rien parce que ce
ne soit enlevée vous dire parce que
c'est pas le texte qui compte c'est le
contexte parce que j'ai fait relire et
étudier tous les interventions du
journal officiel
et qu'est ce qui était dit chaque fois
parce qu'ils s'opposaient à cela c'était
pas de dire je veux pas telle ou telle
région était même tombé d'accord avec
monsieur raffarin de dire aquitaine
poitou charentes limousin après tout
pourquoi pas on aurait pu faire ce pas
en avant nous ne l'avons pas les bien
sûr c'est tout ce qu'il y a derrière je
les compétences des compétences laissées
par monsieur le président guillaume je
peux vous rassurer le groupe qu'est le
mien groupe est en réunion de groupe
hier a décidé de faire une proposition
de carte va très bien donc j'étais pas
votre une on ne peut pas le savoir c'est
dommage
on fera toujours une place mais tout ce
qui est bon donc on a on a décidé que
nous ferions une proposition pour la
deuxième lecture que chacun consul tout
ça et nous allons nous réunir pour
essayer de faire en sorte juste d'avoir
fait maintenant parce que pour une
raison toute simple c'est que cette
carte savez une carte pour les décennies
qu'ils viennent il faut qu'elle ait de
la légion timité si vous faites une
carte de notables si vous faites une
carte d'en haut qui apparaît comme ça
comme une négociation entre barons
locaux comme dit monsieur you à ce
moment là votre carte à la pas de
crédibilité de légitimité avec les
universités à les syndicats les
associations
quand tout le monde est fait exprime si
cette décision est que l'on vient en
phase finale faire l'arbitrage à ce
moment on donnera de la crédibilité mais
très franchement la réforme et dans son
contenu a plus d'intérêt peut-être que
cette seule question de méthode et à
part la carte qu'est ce qui va changer
avec cette réforme territoriale at on
avoir droit à des économies ou pal en
quête de louis civile
la normandie deux régions côte à côte
l'union semble évidente dans le projet
de réforme territoriale
et pourtant en 2008 une étude a été
menée pour savoir si sur la baie
seraient les dépenses publiques le
constat est sans appel la fusion
coûterait 15 millions d'euros et serait
amorti en 20 ans vous avez des économies
d'échelle liées à une mutualisation en
fait d'un certain nombre de travaux de
fonction mais ces économies d'échelle
elles sont quand même limité et cesse et
c'est à dire que si on prend l'exemple
des lycées vous avez des lycées dans
basse normandie des lycées en haute
normandie vous allez pas les regrouper
pour faire des économies d'échelle des
économies bien marginale
la réforme prévoit de diviser les
régions par deux au total le
gouvernement table sur une dizaine de
milliards d'euros d'ici cinq à dix ans
soit 5 % de la masse globale des
collectivités territoriales chez les
parlementaires de gauche ou de droite
personne n'y croit on nous dit je fais
une réforme pour simplifier les
structures territoriales
et cela va apporter des économies et
qu'on ne soit pas capable
d'articuler clairement ces économies de
les chiffrer quand on aura uniformiser
les régions iter des salariés sur huit
ou dix départements dans une nouvelle
région on sera obligé de faire par le
haut donc au niveau des salariés des
nouvelles collectivités sans générer
beaucoup plus de dépenses le budget des
collectivités est d'environ 250
milliards d'euros soit 30 milliards pour
les régions
165 pour les communes et enfin 30 pour
les départements alors où trouver des
économies là où il ya des économies très
importantes à faire c'est au niveau de
tout ce magma les communes les
intercommunalités
les opc les syndicats mix là il faut
mettre les mains dans le cambouis et
commencer à dire qui fait quoi et à
empêcher qui est un recouvrement et des
compétences et aussi ce qui est plus
grave et qui coûte très cher
actuellement un recouvrement des
décideurs
les collectivités territoriales ont déjà
des budgets très serrés l'état leur
supprime 28 milliards d'euros d'ici à
2017 si leur fusion n'est pas une manne
elles devront trouver ailleurs les
ressources financières
alors didier guillaume au départ le
gouvernement nous avait vendu une
dizaine de milliards d'économies c'est
ce qu'avait dit andré vallini qui est
chargée de cette réforme et puis à
l'arrivée on nous dit que finalement il
raterait un peu d'économies ça dépend de
quoi on parle si on parle tout de suite
ou si on parle sur la durée une
invention pas tout de suite tu aura pas
d'économie il y aura toujours du
personnel qui va rester là il faudra
faire ce travail il n'y a pas de sujet
par contre si on se place à cinq ou dix
ans le fait de réduire le nombre de
régions de clarifier les compétences
parce que c'est ça qui est très
important aussi je pense que je porte
oui cinq ans je n'en sais rien à perdre
mais personne ne peut dire mais personne
ne peut dire cela c'est pour ça que je
pense que andré magny est allé un peu
vite dans son expression en même temps
lorsque l'on regarde le budget consolidé
des collectivités locales qui est 250
milliards d'euros si on n'est pas
capable de faire 1 2 ou 3 % dans les dix
ans qui viennent c'est vraiment n'est
pas bon de toute façon nous serons
obligés parce qu'il ya de moins en moins
d'argent il faudra réduire les choses
donc il faut prêter plus dans une je
voudrais qu'on est dans une logique
économique c'est que je suis d'accord
avec ce venir didier guillaume au fond
c'est sur les compétences qu'on va faire
des économies aujourd'hui vous avez un
comité du tourisme régional un comité
départemental à terme il y aura qu'un
seul comité du tourisme et donc on va
simplifier en termes de compétences et
sur les 230 milliards non mais mais
après les soucis ça va quand même à
laisser faire ça va aller a quand même
assez vite mais il est clair que vous
touchez pas à l'histoire de la france à
la géographie de la france comme ça
brutalement et donc nous aurons des
économies qui sont sur les compétences
moi je pense que l'idée d'avoir des
grandes régions qui permet de diminuer
le nombre de régions ça va faire un peu
d'économies de fonctionnement rapidement
par beaucoup mais un petit peu mais
surtout ça vous oblige à vraiment faire
une différence entre la programmation
sur les grandes infrastructures sur les
grands dossiers les universités sur la
politique économique et puis la
proximité que ce soit le département
l'intercommunalité ou là les compétences
ne seront pas en rivalité chacun fera
deux métiers différents et là nous
économiserons beaucoup new soul et 200
contenir si vous économisez 5 % en dix
ans c'est très important aujourd'hui on
est dans un système qui augmente ses
dépenses il vaut mieux être dans un
système qui va les diminuer c'est ce qui
est engagée la forme c'est l'enjeu je
pense que si on vous entend non mais moi
je suis pour la réforme il est clair que
tous les cantons veulent la
décentralisation la décentralisation
c'est très important paris nous dit que
c'est un dossier technique moi je dis
c'est un dossier politique parce que
plus la démocratie elle est proche du
terrain plus on décide mieux c'est donc
je suis parmi les girondins et ça c'est
pas un clivage droite gauche parce qu'il
ya des girondins à gauche et il ya des
jacobins à gauche comme à droite moi je
suis un girondin donc je suis pour une
décentralisation politique donc je crois
que c'est une réforme qui va dans ce
sens on a des discussions c'est normal
c'est pas facile de faire une carte je
crois qu'il faut niqab c'est pas facile
de définir comment général à proximité
département ou intercomités à 1 à des
débats mais c'est ce nas des bases
démocratiques moi je voulais revenir
maintenant sur l'image qu'a donnée le
sénat à l'occasion de cette réforme il y
avait beaucoup de critiques déjà au
moment de la discussion pour la
limitation du cumul là on a encore
entendu des noms un peu péjoratif
concernant des adjectifs un peu
péjoratif que concernant le scénar sénat
jean christophe cambadélis par exemple à
la tête du ps il a critiqué
l'immobilisme du sauna jacques attali ch
il a parlé de corporatisme une assemblée
de rentier est ce qu une fois de plus à
beaucoup affaibli cette discussion le
sénat je me fiche totalement de ce que
dit monsieur attali
sadirac bokou de choz nord il a parlé d'
immobilisme et ben moi je veux bien
qu'on entende pas l'immobilisme mais
quand on regarde la frénésie de
l'assemblée nationale je suis fier
d'être sénateur et aujourd'hui il faut
arrêter ce cinéma si on veut supprimer
le sénat si on veut supprimer le
bicamérisme il faut le dire il n'y a pas
un pays au monde où c'est comme cela
seul e la question que nous devons nous
poser
dans le monde à parakou
non mais attendez la démocratie à part
la corée du nord a par la corée du nord
dans le monde sous la planète le
bicamérisme et park vous attendez
attendez je vais réponse est non je vais
vous répondre on peut supprimer les élus
supprimer les élections et puis
considérer qu'on va dans un autre
système c'est pas linéaire on peut
diminuer le nombre de journalistes
russie sallanches serait aussi un peu
tout diminué mais ne partons pas dans ce
populisme ambiant aujourd'hui nos
concitoyens sont perdus et au moment où
ils sont perdus fowler tracer des pistes
pas dire faute ou diminuer tout est
pourri non il faut avancer et donc
aujourd'hui l'enjeu c'est bien de se
dire il faut un bicamérisme moderne
rénové il faut que le sénat exister pour
tout cela existe il faut qu'il soit fort
il faut qu'il donne des signes il faut
des lois soient votées il faut que des
lois fortes et des voix fortes puisse
s'exprimer c'est ça qui est important
mais vous savez j'étais ferez vous savez
lire était stable écoutez moi comme un
gars né à metz qu'il y ait une majorité
stable d'une majorité stable aujourd'hui
il ya une majorité qui ne s'exprime pas
tous les jours on l'a vu il ya encore
c'est logique on voit bien pourquoi à
l'assemblée nationale on est de l'autre
côté je parlais frénésie tout à l'heure
je sais pas si nos concitoyens qui
regardent le mardi et le mercredi les
questions à l'assemblée nationale ou qui
regardent c'est de là que je perds un
joli ce qu'est ce qu'ils préfèrent vous
noterez que cette critique du sénat
vient de gens qui sont de culture
technocratique s'il n'y avait pas de
politique les technocrates serait bien
plus content bien sûr il déciderait très
vite quand ils veulent parce que ce sont
des experts qui ont l'intelligence la
culture que ces pauvres et lui n'ont pas
et donc tout ce qui consiste à court
circuiter il faut toujours s'en méfier
ce que je crois vraiment c'est que le
sénat est indispensable pour quoi
d'abord pour la navette parce qu'un
texte quand il fait la navette il
haletante descendants et vous avez des
expériences là vous avez les notaires
vous avez les professeurs vous avez les
syndicats qui regardent les textes qui
regardaient débat et qui font remonter
choix l'assemblée soit au sénat leur
réaction c'est à dire que la loi elle se
fait en descendant dans le pays et c'est
à ça que sert la navette et de ce point
de vue là le sénat d'abord parce qu'il a
une bonne qualité juridique ensuite
parce qu'il est bien enracinée dans les
territoires fait remonter les réactions
de la société civile et c'est pour ça
que la loin peut-être le plus partagé
possible il est évident que le sénat
doit être modernisé il est évident que
le sénat doit être réformée lutte il
faut que sergio il faut un sursaut du
sénat j'ai le sentiment personnellement
que depuis un certain temps ça ne date
pas simplement de la président depuis un
certain temps et il y a une forme un peu
de critiques un peu de déclin et pour ça
moi je crois qu'il faut chercher mais
ensemble comment on fait un sursaut
pourra fois assumé sa crédibilité du
sénat et la respectabilité du sénateur
et donc ça c'est un travail qu'on doit
faire ensemble on a fait ce matin avec
le président bayle sur les questions de
financement les groupes politiques ou
ensemble on a pris une décision qui va
dans la bonne direction donc il faut que
le sénat vive son sursaut mais il faut
surtout garder une démocratie vivante et
deux assemblées celle qui vit avec le
temps chaud avec les humeurs l'assemblée
nationale et puis suivirent avec un peu
plus de sagesse que celle du sénat mais
avec de la réflexion il ya aussi des
critiques concernant le mode de scrutin
pour les élections sénatoriales je vous
propose d'écouter le constitutionnaliste
dominique rousseau lui il estime que le
sénat n'est toujours pas assez
représentatifs malgré les récentes
réformes en l'écoutant
suivez cette expression le sénat c'est
le chambre de la seg de la châtaigne bon
on est au 21ème siècle on n'est plus au
19e siècle il faut qu'aujourd'hui le
sénat ne représente pas le seigle et la
châtaigne les représente la métropole
présentait région représente du tout me
dynamisme
de la france du xxième siècle si le
sénat reste de la chan
seigle de la châtaigne elle sera
toujours
considéré comme une chambre suspecte
dans sa légitimité alors que les
sénateurs s'empare très vite de la
question de la composition de leur
assemblée c'est le seul moyen pour
assurer enfin la légitimité du sénat
dans les institutions françaises
j'entendais ce que dit dominique
rousseau c'est assez décalé le maire de
lyon il est sénateur le président de la
région bourgogne il est sénateur et donc
qu'il y avait ouvert ce matin france a
fini il y à une diversité nous sommes
représentatifs des français parce que
nous sommes on attendait des territoires
de ceux qui vivent était il dit les
métropoles et métropole sont présentes
l'intercommunalité présente la ruralité
et présentent donc on peut toujours
discuter mais je me méfie de ceux qui
veulent faire des représentations qui
sont souvent totalement à la
proportionnelle parce qu'à la
proportionnelle on reste c'est équilibré
il ya une part de proportionnelle il ya
une part non proposera elle change de
mode de scrutin je pense qu'il faut
garder un enracinement du sénateur il
faut garder cette élection au suffrage
universel ou deuxième degré ce qui rend
des gens deuxième degré c'est mieux
qu'un direct parce que c'est des frais
de chambre de personnes cette voie là il
faut qu'on soit élu de manière
différente et c'est je crois utile
d'avoir ces deux cultures moi je regarde
toujours avec beaucoup de
d'ironie le dédain de ces personnes car
lorsqu'il parle des élus et du sénat
parce que bien sûr eux ils savent tous
nous avons de jeunes de chambre il faut
deux chants qu'ils ne soient pas élus de
la même façon l'assemblée nationale sont
les élus du peuple et sont élus
directement et peut-être à la
proportionnelle totalement mais si on
avait une deuxième chambre qui était lui
de la même façon il n'y aura pas de
deuxième chance ce seraient les mêmes
donc le sénat y des verts ils
représentaient territoire il faut un
sénat fort à senna moderniser un scénar
respecter c'est ça l'enjeu que nous
avons grandi l'enjeu c'est un jeu de
tous les jours les élections de
du mois de septembre on dit vais pouvoir
nous répondre que ce serait perdue à
gauche c'est pas moi hier soir je
pensais que le brésil pouvait l'emporter
finalement ils ont pris une sacrée
raclée donc je ne peux pas vous dire si
je ne peux pas vous dire qu'une gagnera
la mémoire propre politique du chiffre
est politique je ne suis ni un
commentateur néo raillé un pronostiqueur
d'un pronostiqueurs
je pense
sénatoriales bien sûr bien sûr je
regardais petit pronostiqueur aucun
pronostic je regarde la façon de la plus
rationnelle possible et je pense que
avant les municipales nous étions
favoris aujourd'hui nous sommes
challengers je pense que c'est la merde
si c'est un beau débat et ses essais et
c'est ouvert nous verrons bien alors je
pense que l'un des probabilités de
gagner le sénat qui sont assez fortes
mais qu'ils sont toujours incertaine je
pense que les réductions municipales
font que en 2014 le résultat est
incertain en 2017 il est très probable
que la même génération de mer va faire
deux générations deux sénateurs le
projet que allemande et ces changements
c'est 2017 je pense que l'euro gagné
donc là c'est assez incertain nous avons
de bonnes probabilités mais je crois
qu'il faut qu'on travaille à une
modernisation du sénat et voyez que au
fond on a dit quoi d'accord
candidats non franchement c'est au delà
de ces pour répondre à cette question
qu'on va débarquer là sur le mode de l
ce qui me paraît important aujourd'hui
c'est qu'il faut qu'on travaille droite
et gauche ensemble sur un certain nombre
de sujets j'ai lu le livre par exemple
d'hubert védrine récemment où il fait un
certain nombre de professions de cette
nature il faut trouver un lieu où dans
l'allier un africain sur les fonds non
mais attendez mais ont su sénat vous me
parlez d'une opération lancée par le
gouvernement cet autre chose moi je vous
dis que quand vous demandez au sénat jeu
et on a été capable de faire des textes
en sang moi je crois qu'il nous faut
travailler dans nos institutions quand
vous voyez que les allemands font face à
la crise ont tous ensemble que madame
merkel et son hôte sur didier guillaume
et ses alliances il faut il faut
chercher il faut chercher un travail
différent du travail frontale que nous
avons dans la vème république française
c'est ce travail frontale qui nous
empêchent aujourd'hui de trouver un
certain nombre de solutions vous voyez
c'est un bon exemple squeeze sur le
texte parce qu'au fond sur le fond des
choses on est à ses voisins et en fait
on est opposée sur des questions de
méthode guillaumin oui je faisais il
faut un sémaphore moderniser et respecté
il faut un sémaphore à senna qui parle
d'une voix forte et pour parler d'une
voix forte une faute sur certains textes
c'est pas une coalition d'autres grosses
droite c'est quand il fait jour mais
j'ai pas de prix pour ça quand il fait
jour à midi faut que tout le monde dise
qu'il fait jour à midi parce que
certains disent qu'il fait nuit ça ne va
pas donc senna force un sénat qui sur
les grands enjeux se retrouve en au delà
des clivages politiques fois un scénar
moderniser parce qu'on voit bien les
questions vous avez posé ce que disait
le constitutionnaliste il faut faire
passer ses possessions mais bien sûr que
les français se pourrait très bien que
l'image enfin écouter les français pour
l'instant il se pose c'est de france et
pour la salle se pose la question de
savoir comment ils habitent et comment
ils mangent là aussi des questions mais
justement il donc il faut moderniser le
sénat un bicamérisme modernisée qui est
indispensable puis un scénar respectés
et pour être respecté il faut qu'ils
puissent parler à l'exécutif quelle que
soit la tendance des uns et des autres
et qu'ils puissent être entendus c'est
tout l'enjeu nous avons essayé de faire
sur la réforme territoriale par exemple
sur les départements etc sur la ruralité
et il faut le faire sur tous les sujets
si nous arrivons à avoir un sénat fort
moderniser et respecté je crois que
l'image du sénat reprendra
savoir résister le président du sénat
dans le passé ont su le faire là dedans
différentes mais le président
vous président du sénat en 2014 vous
serez résister et vous à moi je pense
que la résistance du sénat c'est quelque
chose de très important et je regrette
qu'on ait pris et je regrette que je
regrette c'est pas ça la question à la
question cédait résister à son propre
gouvernement je pense que dans le passé
sur certaines réformes territoriales y
compris sociales n'est que la serbie
nous n'avons pas assez résisté sur le
pont ce lait quand un certain nombre
d'autres présidents ont donné de la
force au sénat c'est quand ils ont
réussi à résister aux conseillers
territoriaux
la taxe professionnelle la carte de
l'intercommunalité il faut savoir
résister mais il faut aussi savoir
proposer et donc c'est là où on a besoin
de cette modernisation dont parle d'aidé
guillon voyez dit guillaume si vous
voulez pas perdre le sénat en septembre
savoir résister à l'exécutif à mes jeux
mais nous l'avons fait sur la réforme
territoriale je pense que nous avons
marqué un sacré point c'est pour ça que
si nous étions sortis avec un texte là
on aurait vraiment gagner et c'est
quelque chose que vous pourriez défendre
si vous gardez le sénat sera candidat à
la présidence du sénat sa vie et deux
erreurs à ne pas commettre en politique
la première erreur c'est d'être candidat
sur un poste qui n'est pas vacant donc
le poste est vacant
en septembre il le sent il le sera en
septembre mais si on gagne il a étudié
la deuxième erreur à ne pas commettre
c'est si on est en situation ces deux
passes présenté sera posté vacant allez
pour finir très vite et ça c'est assez
juste ce qu'il dit je trouve
pour finir très vite on écoute le
dernier sans doute constitutionnaliste
s'appelle mathilde g et elle trouve que
le sénat porte malheur écoutez là
c'est une chambre utile mais je dirais
de manière provocatrice comme je me
rappelle toujours à mes étudiants que
c'est surtout une chambre qui porte
malheur qui porte malheur puisque
ensuite à des référendums négatifs sur
la question du sénat
les personnalités de premier plan ont dû
démissionner j'ai pensé que ce général
de gaulle en 1964 on peut remonter
encore plus loin le premier projet de
constitution de 1946 qui on se le
rappelle
comportait pas des véritables sénat qui
a été rejetée par les électeurs et puis
plus récemment un ancien pour nos
ministres du 2002 juste avant de le
perdre on faisait le premier tour des
élections présidentielles avait appelé
la suppression du sénat où les critiquer
fortement dans le monde et c'est là
encore lui apporter mais est-ce qu'être
sénateurs porte malheur
bon c'est sa théorie dj guillaume n'est
pas d'accord non je suis pas d'accord
elle dit que ça portait malheur un
premier ministre a porté bonheur à 9
alors qu'est ce que c'est que cette
histoire ça je discute tout ça avec
droit vous avez trop de pas être
d'accord évidemment mais c'est que c'est
une chambre à part le sénat est d'accord
mais s'il fonctionne pas mais comme dans
tous les autres pays du monde il ya deux
chambres et le sénat français a des
choses à dire des choses à faire doit
être respectée on doit faire des
propositions c'est tout l'enjeu de la
campagne mais c'est tout l'enjeu du
sénat de tous les jours et à partir de
là pourquoi toujours s'acharner sur le
sénat alors que c'est l'assemblée des
territoires on voudrait une france et
ses petits zay une france sans aucune
aspérité une fonction d'entraîneur puis
et puis très technocratique regarder
poncelet prenez m'honore enel prenait
belle vous avez des profils politiques
qui ne sont pas de la marche et par les
nigérians gérard larcher aussi bien sûr
et qu'elle ne se sont pas de profil de
technocrate ce sont des profils de jean
enraciné à rambouillet pour cete gérard
larcher mon ami et donc il y à une un
travail qui est fait par le sénat qui
est une différence et finalement quand
vous voyez que monsieur monory avec son
certificat d'études réussi est remise de
l'éducation ministre de l'économie et se
comporte comme un exemple de réussite de
l'offensive à vous vous dites qu'il ya
des fiertés ya des sûretés tous ses
repas simplement l' expertise
technocratique qui est la voie du
progrès merci à tous les deux d'être
venu sur ce plateau ces duels au sénat
un des duels qu'on peut bien sûr
retrouver sur notre site
c'est notre site internet
si vous voulez revoir cette poignée de
main c'est évidemment sur
www.publicsenat.fr bonne journée